welcome to the exciting world of devops
engineering where Innovation meets
efficiency to transform software
development and operations into seamless
and agile process in this video on
devops engineering roadmap 2024 we will
be covering what is devops devops
engineering roadmap responsibilities of
devops engineer salary and companies
hiring let me ask you a quick question
so which of the following is a key
objective of devops option A is slowing
down software development option b is
increasing the gap between development
and operations option C is automating
and streamlining software delivery
option D is reducing collaboration among
teams now you can pause this video and
answer in the comment section below
alright so now let's start with the
first topic which is what is devops
so devops is a collaborative approach
that brings together software
development that is Dev and ID operation
that is Ops teams to streamline the
software delivery process it emphasizes
communication collaboration automation
to enable faster and more Reliable
Software releases devops aims to break
down the wall between teams allowing for
seamless integration and continuous
feedback throughout the development life
cycle by automating tasks such as code
testing deployment and infrastructure
management devops promote and stability
ultimately devops Fosters a culture of
collaboration Innovation and continuous
Improvement enabling organizations to
deliver high quality software at faster
Pace to meet customer demands if you
inspire to become a devops engineer
simply learns professional certificate
program in cloud computing and devops is
your ideal choice in partnership with E
and ICT Academy IIT guwahati this
program equips you with the skills
needed to excel in cloud computing and
devops learn to deploy robust Microsoft
Azure and AWS applications through a
blend of live virtual class Hands-On
Labs self-paced videos and collaborative
peer interactions don't miss this
opportunity to master the art of cloud
and devops enroll today and pave your
way to become a cloud expert
all right now let's move on and
understand the devops engineering
roadmap so the devops engineers need to
possess a diverse set of skills so let's
explore the importance of key skills in
the devops engineer roadmap first we
have is Linux Linux is an open source
operating systems widely used in the
devops world devops Engineers need to be
familiar with Linux as it is commonly
used for Server management scripting and
automation understanding Linux commands
and system administrations helps in
effectively managing infrastructure
next skill is Jenkins CI CD continuous
integration and continuous delivery
deployment that is CI CD are essential
practices in devops Jenkins is a popular
tool for automating the CI CD pipeline
allowing for frequent code integration
testing and deployment devops Engineers
need to understand Jenkins to enable
faster and more Reliable Software
releases
the next skill that you must possess in
order to become a devops engineer is
Docker and Docker swamp containerization
with Docker allows for consistent and
portable application deployments devops
Engineers use Dockers to package
applications and their dependencies into
containers making them easier to manage
and deploy Docker swarm helps in
orchestralization and scaling
containerization applications ensuring
High availability and efficient resource
utilization
coming to the next one which is
kubernetes kubernetes is crucial for
managing containerization application at
a scale it automates the deployment
scaling and management of containers
making it easier to manage complex
environments devops Engineers need to
understand kubernetes to ensure
efficient resource allocations High
availability and seamless application
scaling all right now moving on to the
next skill which is cloud platforms so
Cloud platforms provide on-demand
resources and services enabling
scalability and flexibility devops
Engineers need to be proficient in Cloud
platforms like AWS Azure or Google Cloud
to deploy and manage applications in the
cloud this allows for efficient resource
provisioning scalability and cost
optimization
next up we have is Version Control
System
so Version Control Systems like git are
essential for collaboration and managing
code changes devops Engineers use
Version Control System to track changes
collaborate with team members and ensure
code integrity
it enables efficient core management
versioning and collaboration across
teams following this there is monitoring
and logging monitoring and logging tools
are crucial for tracking applications
and infrastructure performance devops
Engineers set up monitoring systems to
proactively identify issues troubleshoot
problems and ensure Optimal Performance
and availability logging helps in
capturing and analyzing applications
logs for debugging and performance
optimization each of these skills plays
a vital role in enabling collaboration
Automation scalability and reliability
in the devops workflow they help devops
Engineers streamline process improve
efficiency and deliver high quality
software at a faster pace now let's talk
about the responsibilities of a devops
engineer so as a devops engineer your
responsibilities revolve around Bridging
the Gap between development and
operation teams to ensure smooth and
efficient software delivery here are
some key responsibilities explained in
the understandable manner first is
collaboration here collaboration means
you work closely with development
operations and other cross-functional
teams to Foster collaborations and
streamline communication
and performance hair Monitor and
performance means you set up monitoring
systems to track the performance and
health of applications and
infrastructure this helps in identifying
and resolving issues proactively then
third is release Management in this you
manage the release process coordinating
with different teams to plan and execute
software releases
all right next is continuous integration
and deployment in this you automate the
process of integration code changes from
developers and deploying them to the
production environments
next is troubleshooting and support in
troubleshooting and support you
investigate and resolve issues related
to application or infrastructure
performance working closely with
development and operation teams
then there is continuous Improvement in
continuous Improvement you continuously
evaluate and improve existing processes
tools and infrastructure to enhance
efficiency and scalability right then
there is security and compliance in this
you implement security measures and best
practices to protect applications and
infrastructure from potential threats
all right so this was about the
responsibilities of a devops engineer
now let's talk about the interesting
part which is the salary all right so on
an average a devops engineer in the
United States can expect to earn between
138 thousand dollars per positions may
start around 70 to 90 000 per year it's
important to note that these figures are
approximate and can vary significantly
based on individual circumstances all
right so this was the salary now let's
talk about the companies hiring for
devops engineer so first of all there is
Mercedes-Benz research and development
India a company based in Bengaluru India
that requires devops Engineers with
skills in AWS kubernetes Docker Jenkins
and python the next big company is IBM a
multinational company that has openings
for devops engineering then there is
Flipkart Flipkart a leading e-commerce
company that is looking for devops
engineers with expertise in Linux git
terraform and monitoring tools next
company is core over a remote company
that offers full-time positions for
devops engineers with experience in
Integrations updates fixes and technical
support
then there is Accenture Accenture is
currently seeking devops Engineers to
optimize their ID operations and
software development processes then
Oracle Oracle is actively recruiting
devops Engineers to enhance their ID
operations and streamline software
development
at last we have is sap sap is looking
for devops engineers to improve their ID
operations and software development
practices as you follow this devops
roadmap keep in mind that it's not just
a path but an ongoing Journey embrace
the idea of always learning things
easier with automation as you hit each
Milestone you will not only make things
run smoother but also create a culture
of teamwork and Improvement in your
workplace alright guys with that we have
come to the end of this video If you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up I hope it really help you all thanks
for watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign